joining me now ukrainian parliament
member alexandra ustinova um
your president uh has been increasingly
scathing about the
uh western response
um
obviously appreciative of what help's
been given but wanting a lot more what's
your position on that tonight
i can tell this is the position of every
ukrainian because we have thousands of
people die every day more than 200
schools destroyed so far the response of
the west was very weak it looks like
everybody is scared of putin because the
sanctions are partial because for
example the energy sector was excluded
and there is no embargo in oil and gas
you know just to compare it would be the
same if let's say kelvin klein left the
russian market and said well we're not
going to sell
jeans there but we can kept the rest of
the
clothes in the stores that's what
actually is happening right now in the
world also we've been talking about the
banking sanctions well the swift that
was promised to be switched off for the
russian banks unfortunately was switched
off only for seven out of 300 banks that
are there in russia so we keep look we
keep watching how the world is trying to
trying to protect their economies not to
step in and fight even in the economics
with russians
also if you look at the response in the
military sphere we don't ask to be
protected we don't need the
us or uk or nato soldiers to come over
and fight for ukraine the only thing we
kept asking was the air defense systems
that can protect our sky because
missiles and bombs are the key problem
for us that are killing thousands of
civilians and putin is doing the best in
re in actually implementing his strategy
because his strategy is simple to kill
as many civilians as he can and then to
put us at the table for negotiations we
have big cities surrounded by the
russian army right now for example the
city of mariupol which is 400 000 people
which is half of the size of washington
dc totally surrounded by the russian
army and they do not let people women
children to get out no safe corridors
and they cannot be enforced because
russians start
shooting just civilians and people are
starving to death at the moment in the
city and cannot get out that's why of
course every ukrainian so as the
president zelansky keep asking for the
support that was promised for us 20
years ago we gave up our nukes we were
one of the largest of the country who
had the largest nuclear weapon
ammunition and we gave it up for the
promise that we would have the
protection from the united states the
united kingdom and russia if anything
happens well this is not happening we
cannot even get you to do the sanctions
on oil and gas which is the main income
for putin i know
well you know what thank you so much for
being so forceful and clear about that
and what is so infuriating about that
last point about the oil and gas is that
putting those sanctions in place and
then ramping up u.s supply so we replace
russian oil and gas with american oil
and gas would actually help america and
we're not doing that and that is
infuriating alexandra thank you so much
i can see you in washington dc i hope
people are listening to you thank you
for joining us tonight hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else